I must have gotten three or four dozen emails
over the weekend about Donald Trump going
to the hospital for a multi hour unplanned
visit.
It wasn't on his schedule with speculation,
just running rampant about what this is related
to and some of the people who emailed me about
this were speculating that maybe this is related
to Trump's cognitive decline, but you don't
get rushed to a hospital unexpectedly for
cognitive decline.
You schedule a meeting with an urologist and
you get tested.
So I don't believe that that's what this is
about.
Now, the white house in retrospect is saying
that these were tests related to Trump's 2020
annual physical, but it really doesn't make
sense because again, it wasn't on Trump's
schedule and the hospital didn't know Trump
was coming.
And I'll get to that later.
What is very clear is that the white house
doesn't seem to be telling the truth about
this.
The more they speak, the more it sounds odd
because Trump's press secretary said Trump
is quote, anticipating a very busy 2020 and
therefore wanted to take advantage of a quote
free weekend in Washington to just get ahead
on some portions of his routine checkup not
scheduled until next year doesn't really make
much sense.
And I'll tell you why in a second.
Donald Trump also tweeting quote, visited
a great family of a young man under major
surgery at the amazing Walter Reed medical
center.
Those are truly some of the best doctors in
the world.
Also began phase one of my yearly physical,
everything.
Good, great.
Actually we'll complete next year.
Now why would we doubt this?
There are many reasons.
First showing up unexpectedly in November
of 2019 for parts of the physical, not scheduled
until 2020 when Trump's past physicals have
just lasted four hours and he was there for
two hours this time.
It just doesn't really make any sense and
then you add to this that Trump just had a
physical nine months ago.
It also doesn't make sense that he would be
rushing in months early to get another physical,
or at least part of one done add to this that
Walter Reed hospital says, we didn't know
Trump was coming.
He was not scheduled to be here.
If you're coming in for two hours of tests
and you're the president, you can be damn
sure that the hospital knows that you're coming.
Karen Tumulty has a good piece in the Washington
post which should guide us, which explains
that even when the white house is explanations
make sense or appear to make sense, they are
very often lies.
They lie all the time.
They lie about everything, even insignificant
things.
When the white house, his explanation does
not make sense.
You can be almost certain that it's a lie.
And here the explanation makes absolutely
no sense whatsoever.
And in fact, claims around Donald Trump's
health haven't made sense for a very long
time.
Remember, uh, claiming that, um, he is six
foot three when Obama is 61 and in any picture
of them together, Trump is clearly shorter
than Barack Obama.
That never made sense.
But it was useful to try to have numbers on
paper that make Trump just short of obese
rather than obese.
The letter from Trump's old doctor Harold
Bornstein, that Trump would be the healthiest
president ever when he was at the time, I
believe 70 or 71 eats food constantly, arguably
obese, if not borderline obese.
And Bornstein of course, hadn't examined any
other presidents.
How could Harold Bornstein say Trump would
be the healthiest president ever?
It didn't make sense.
You would have to be very dim to believe that
Donald Trump not scheduled for medical exams
until next year would say, Hey, you know what?
I'm not golfing this weekend.
What the hell?
Let's go do two hours of testing at Walter
Reed even though they have no idea that I'm
coming.
There is no chance that that's the real explanation.
Now, my mere speculation is that Trump went
in for something like chest pain or something
along those lines, possibly a panic attack.
This is the type of thing where someone feels
as though they can't breathe and their chest
hurts.
They go in, they have a workup done.
Doctors check to see if you've had a heart
attack, and very often they come out and say,
you didn't have a heart attack.
It seems that this was a panic attack.
Trump is not a healthy guy.
He doesn't exercise.
He's overweight and nearly to the point of
obesity or obesity, depending on what numbers
you believe.
He eats terribly.
He's 73 years old at some point.
One would imagine that that would have repercussions.
If I had to bet, I would say panic or anxiety
related chest pain, I don't blame the guy.
Things are not going well.
The walls closing in Roger Stone indicted
on seven counts, uh, impeachment inquiry,
another loss in Louisiana, things not looking
good for Trump.
That is my best guess.
And it is merely a guest last thought.
If Trump does abuse uppers, amphetamines as
it increasingly seems that he does and we're
going to talk about that momentarily, those
can make someone feel like they are having
a heart attack and it wouldn't be remotely
surprising if it was related, if indeed that
is what Donald is doing.
Of course, Trump not seen publicly or by the
white house press Corps other than when he
left the hospital as of this recording of
the segment up until now, tweeting, certainly
tweeting nonstop but also not seen publicly.
Uh, in any kind of capacity.
We will see if we ever learn the truth with
the Trump administration very often we never
do.